.
Luft: Sie ist allgegenwärtig,
unsichtbar und unverzichtbar.
Sie ist ein Sinnbild für Weite,
für enorme Kräfte,
für Freiheit.
Mit ihr können wir schweben,
atmen und träumen.
Die Luft ist ihr Element.
Dominic und Sascha
jagen Tornados in den USA.
Dort unten, Tornado!
Oh, schön, super!
Misha und Christian
betreiben in Afrika
ihre eigene Rettungsflugwacht.
Wir fliegen von Maun nach Gaborone,
dort nehmen wir einen Patienten auf.
Stefan
fährt mit seinem Heissluftballon
über die argentinischen Anden.
Es fühlt sich an wie Weihnachten
und Ostern zusammen.
Missionspilot Daniel kämpft in Süd-
ostasien um das Leben der Passagiere.
Die Gefahr ist, dass man wegschaut
und es einfach ausblendet.
Hier bin ich tagtäglich
damit konfrontiert.
Und Jonas will Schweizermeister
im Segelkunstflug werden.
Es macht Spass,
aber es gibt noch einiges zu lernen.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Die Tornadojagd beginnt im
amerikanischen Bundesstaat Texas.
Im Mai geht hier nämlich
die Tornado-Saison los.
Dominic
reist mit seinen Freund Sascha.
Die beiden Stormchaser lernten sich
vor elf Jahren in der Schweiz kennen.
Die Aufgaben sind klar verteilt:
Sascha sitzt am Steuer und Dominic
sucht am Laptop nach Sturmzellen.
Ich betreibe Stormchasing
wegen der Faszination vor der Natur.
Es ist einfach toll zu sehen,
was das Wetter alles machen kann.
Die Gewalt und Kraft der Natur spürt
man hier in den Staaten extrem gut.
Mir gibt es Kraft und Energie
für den Alltag.
Wenn man hier so ein Erfolgserlebnis
hat - das nimmt man mit.
An den drei Wochen,
die ich hier in den Staaten bin,
werde ich fast ein ganzes Jahr lang
zehren.
Es ist, wie wenn jemand Schlümpfe
sammelt oder so etwas.
Ich sammle einfach
quasi meine Tornados.
Über ein Jahr lang haben
die beiden die Reise vorbereitet -
jetzt müssen sie nur noch zur rich-
tigen Zeit am richtigen Ort sein.
* Perlende Klänge *
In der Nähe von El Reno
legen sie einen Zwischenstopp
bei einer Gedenkstätte ein.
Hier kamen drei Stormchaser
bei der Jagd nach den Riesenstürmen
ums Leben.
2015 gab es diese Tafel noch nicht.
Das ist schön gemacht.
Sie waren zu dritt unterwegs,
es war am 31. Mai 2013.
Es gab bei El Reno
einen alles zerstörenden Tornado.
Bei El Reno
gab es einen grossen Tornado.
Und rundherum
wirbelten kleinere Tornados.
Und sie wurden von einem kleineren
getroffen.
Tim Samares war noch im Auto,
dieses wurde angehoben
es wurde weit weg gewindet.
Paul und Carl
wurden aus dem Auto hinausgezogen.
Sie waren mit dem Sicherheitsgurt
angeschnallt -
aber es entstand so eine Kraft, dass
sie aus dem Auto gezogen wurden.
Das sind die Gegenstände,
die man im Auto gefunden hat,
oder irgendwo verteilt waren.
Sicherheit geht vor.
Ich bin Vater von zwei Kindern.
Ich will noch erleben,
wie sie erwachsen werden.
Das ist wichtig.
Das Frühstück im Nirgendwo
ist Nebensache.
Die zwei Sturmjäger
lassen die Wetterlage
keine Sekunde aus den Augen.
Das Problem ist die Zugrichtung.
Die ist so wie jetzt.
- Wo ist der Triple Point?
Den habe ich hier ausgemacht.
Der Hagelkern kommt weiter rüber.
Gibt es schon einen Kern?
- Hier ist ein Hagelkern.
Bleibt der nicht hängen?
- Doch.
Eigentlich bleibt er hängen,
es sei denn, er hat ein Eigenleben.
Wir warten noch 5 Min.
und essen fertig.
Dann fahren wir in diese Richtung.
Angezogen
von der Magie der Naturgewalt,
fasziniert von der möglichen Gefahr,
steuern Dominic und Sascha
auf die Gewitterzelle zu,
aus der ein Tornado werden soll.
Ich schaue
die aktuelle Modellprognose an.
Die zeigt an,
wo mögliche Superzellen sind.
D.h.: Wie sieht es in der Höhe aus,
welche Winde gibt es?
Wie ist die Windschärung? Also
einerseits die Drehung der Winde,
es können auch stärkere Winde sein,
hier gibt es Orkanstärke.
Wenn es eine Superzelle hat,
begünstigt das einen Tornado.
Ein Tornado entsteht eigentlich nur
aus einer Superzelle.
Wir müssen uns sowieso verschieben.
Wir müssen ca. 4 Std.
Richtung Westen.
Morgen werden wir also
nochmals 8-12 Std. fahren -
je nachdem, wohin wir wollen.
Die Prognose, die er jetzt
anschaut, für Freitagabend, zeigt,
wo wirklich die ganz starken Gewit-
ter sind, die uns interessieren.
Und das ist ...
... auch eine Kunst,
er muss das genau sehen,
sonst sind wir plötzlich mittendrin,
was etwas tödlich sein kann.
Das versuchen wir also zu vermeiden.
(Lachend) Etwas tödlich ...
* Perlende Klänge *
Botswana im Süden
des afrikanischen Kontinents.
Hier lebt der Schweizer
Christian Gross.
Er gründete vor sechs Jahren
die Okavango Air Rescue.
Eine Rettungsflugwacht
ähnlich der Schweizer Rega.
Wir haben einen Flug
von Gaborone nach Durban.
Jetzt fliegen wir
von Maun nach Gaborone.
Dort nehmen wir den Patienten auf.
In ca. 10 Min. sind wir in der Luft.
Christian ist Unternehmer,
die Einsätze fliegt sein Team.
Meistens mit dabei
ist auch Misha Kruck:
Sie ist Notfallärztin
und Christians Lebenspartnerin.
Mit dieser PC-12 aus der Schweiz
hebt sie fast täglich ab,
um Leben zu retten.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik,
Motorengeräusche *
Heute haben wir ein acht Tage altes
Neugeborenes,
das eine sog. Transposition
der grossen Gefässe hat.
D.h. die Anschlüsse vom Herzen
zur Lunge und zum Körper
sind nicht
in der richtigen Reihenfolge.
Und dadurch bekommt das Kind
nicht genug Sauerstoff
in sein System.
Wenn man das nicht
operativ reparieren wird,
wird das Kind in den nächsten Tagen
sterben.
Die Herausforderung beim Flug ist,
dass diese Verbindung vom Herzen
nicht durch zu viel Sauerstoffgabe
geschlossen wird.
Dann wären wir
in grossen Schwierigkeiten.
Der Flug kann von absolut easy
bis zu hoch kompliziert enden.
Wir hoffen natürlich,
dass es absolut easy ist.
Wir geben unser Bestes,
dass es so sein wird.
Die Basis der Okavango Air Rescue
liegt im Städtchen Maun,
mitten im Okavangodelta.
Die Gegend ist bekannt
für ihre vielen wilden Tiere
und beliebt bei Touristen.
Von hier aus fliegt das Team
von Misha und Christian
seine Einsätze in das unwegsame
Gebiet des Okovango-Flusses.
Für den Weltenbummler Christian
ist Botswana ein Zuhause geworden.
Mit knapp 20
wanderte ich aus der Schweiz aus.
Ich lebte mein ganzes Leben
im Ausland.
Heute in Botswana.
Die Okawango Air Rescue
gibt es seit sechs Jahren.
In den ersten zwei Jahren
waren die Leute etwas misstrauisch,
ob wir das erste Jahr
überleben würden.
Aber wir sind jedes Jahr
stetig gewachsen.
Wir haben rund 30 Angestellte.
Momentan vier Ärzte
und vier Piloten.
Und Krankenschwestern, Paramedics,
Notfallsanitäter.
Somit wurde das keine Halbpensio-
nierung, sondern ein Vollzeitjob.
Und das ist gross.
Mittlerweile landen Misha
und ihre Crew in Gaborone.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Wie ist sein Name?
- Kensington.
Willkommen in unserem
kleinen Flugzeug, Kensington.
Hast du gehört,
du bekommst ein Privatflugzeug.
Lass uns kurz Hallo sagen.
Das ist Kensington.
Und Kensington fliegt nach Durban
für eine grosse Operation.
Und jetzt bringen wir ihn
in unser kleines Bett
und machen es ihm dort schön bequem.
Thank you.
* Sie spricht leise mit ihm. *
Okay, it's going to be alright.
Just for a second, ja, ja, I know.
Misha und ich
trafen uns in der Luft.
Vor elf Jahren ging ich auf
die Jagd, aber nur für zwei Tage.
Dann wollte ich noch nach Spanien,
um meine Mutter zu besuchen.
Wir sassen im Flugzeug und
hatten schon 6 Std. Verspätung.
Die Atmosphäre im Flugzeug
war sehr angespannt.
Das war eine kleine Gruppe,
sechs Leute, auch Christian.
Und die Dame, die auf der anderen
Seite sass, war Misha.
Sie arbeitete ja in den Bergen.
Und als ich ganz verspätet, mit
meiner Jagdkluft ins Flugzeug kam,
meinte sie: "Der Mann aus den Ber-
gen fliegt wohl zum ersten Mal."
Die Stewardess fragte ihn dann,
ob er etwas trinken wollte,
ob alles in Ordnung sei.
Er hat kein Wort verstanden
und ich dachte mir:
"Jesses, das ist auch so ein
Sozialfall, dem muss ich helfen."
"Der hört nicht mal gut."
So kamen wir ins Gespräch.
Wir fanden uns offensichtlich
sympathisch.
Und ... Ja, the rest is history.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Das Baby und seine Mutter haben den
90-minütigen Flug gut überstanden.
# You stay young, that's your fault,
there's so much you need to know ...
Sag Tschüss zu unseren zwei Piloten.
Sie haben dich sicher nach Durban
geflogen, um dein Leben zu retten.
Du wirst uns sicher vermissen.
Hello, I'm Doctor Misha, hello.
Er wird noch am gleichen Tag
am Herzen operiert.
Er wird den Eingriff
bestens überstehen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Ja, wir sind auf dem Weg.
Okay, wunderbar. Bis gleich.
Ciao.
2 Std. später. Misha ist zurück
in Maun und hat endlich Feierabend.
Zu Hause wartet Ehemann Christian
bereits mit dem Nachtessen.
Hunger?
- Ja.
Oh, das sieht gut aus.
Das ist genau, was die Frau braucht.
Zum Essen
kommt Misha trotzdem noch nicht.
Ein Safari Ranger kommt vorbei.
This part of my body is fine.
Es ist nur hier der Arm,
der nicht sehr gut aussieht.
Setz dich da hin.
Ich schau's mir schnell an.
Der Ranger
wurde von einer Spinne gebissen.
Oh, fuck.
- Is it bad?
Okay, du brauchst eine Infusion,
Antibiotika, Schmerzmittel -
und einen Whiskey!
Schau, diese Pillen habe ich gestern
in der Apotheke gekauft.
Ja, die sind nichts.
Nein, die sind nichts.
Es tut sogar noch mehr weh.
Dass die Spinnenbisse schwerwiegende
Krankheitsbilder hervorrufen,
liegt meist daran, dass ihre
Gefährlichkeit nicht erkannt wird.
Das kann ganz böse ausgehen,
wenn man es nicht mit Antibiotika
aggressiv behandelt.
Es ist unglaublich,
wie sehr sowas Kleines schmerzt.
Es fühlt sich an, als ob es
bis auf den Knochen runter ginge.
Ja, das würde es auch.
Vielen Dank und zum Wohl.
- To your good health.
Auf eure Gesundheit auch.
Auch in Andwil in St. Gallen
lebt ein Mann,
der sich mit Leib und Seele
dem Element Luft verschrieben hat.
In seiner Werkstatt bereitet sich
Ballonpilot Stefan Zeberli
auf eine abenteuerliche Reise vor.
Ja, jetzt ist es perfekt.
Aber etwas höher.
Mit seinem Co-Piloten Urs
will Stefan in Argentinien
auf 7'000 m ü. M. aufsteigen
und mit dem Ballon
über die Anden fahren.
Als Profi-Ballonfahrer unternimmt
Stefan rund 200 Fahrten pro Jahr.
Aber keine ist vergleichbar mit dem,
was er in Argentinien vorhat.
Wir bereiten den Korb
für Argentinien vor.
Er kommt auf eine Palette, geht dann
mit der Spedition nach Spanien,
dann mit dem Schiff
nach Argentinien.
Damit wir dort einen
funktionierenden Ballon haben,
checken wir jetzt alles: den Bren-
ner, die Sauerstoffeinrichtung ...
Damit wir nicht dort etwas merken,
was man hier hätte vermeiden können.
Bei Fahrten in solche Gebirge,
wo wir sehr hoch steigen,
nehmen wir Sauerstoff mit.
Danke.
Die Höhe macht auch müde. Das darf
man auch nicht ausser Acht lassen.
Man muss vor einer solchen Ballon-
fahrt also auch körperlich fit sein.
Wie im Spital.
Wie viele Stunden hält eine Flasche?
Nehmen wir nur eine mit?
Wir schicken zwei Zweiliter-
flaschen. Das ist eine mit 3,5 l.
Nur die besten Piloten der Welt
trauen sich eine solche Fahrt zu.
Die Bedingungen sind extrem.
Auf 4'000 m sind es 80 km/h,
auf 5'000 m 120 km/h.
Dort brauchen wir den Wind, oder?
Genau, das brauchen wir
bei der langen Fahrt über Chile.
Eine Herausforderung
ist schon einmal die neue Umgebung.
Das Wetter -
niemand ist wirklich vertraut damit.
Und man kann keine eigenen,
lokalen Erfahrungswerte einbringen.
Das ist eine Grundschwierigkeit, die
man in einem fremden Land halt hat.
Hello.
- Hello, Joseph.
Die Fahrt über die Anden
wird von einem Profi organisiert.
Joseph hat 50 Ballonfahrer
aus der ganzen Welt dazu eingeladen.
Nebst all den üblichen Heraus-
forderungen wartet dieses Mal
ein ganz besonderes Naturspektakel
auf die Ballonfahrer:
eine totale Sonnenfinsternis
im Westen Argentiniens.
Wir müssen zur richtigen Zeit
am vordefinierten Ort sein.
Zur richtigen Zeit
auf der richtigen Höhe.
Also: Die Sonnenbrille
nicht vergessen.
Das ist für mich ballonfahrerisch
gesehen schon das Highlight.
Ich stelle mir das natürlich
auch extrem spannend vor.
Diese kurzen Minuten mitzuerleben,
in denen tagsüber auf einem schmalen
Streifen totale Dunkelheit herrscht.
Ist gut?
Um diese totale Sonnenfinsternis
aus dem Ballon mitzuerleben,
braucht Stefan
beste Wetterverhältnisse,
einwandfreies Material
und ein bisschen Glück.
Auf der anderen Seite der Erdkugel,
am Fusse der Anden,
liegt der kleine Ort Uspallata.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Stefan ist am Vorabend angekommen.
Heute fahren er und die übrigen
Ballonfahrer zum Basecamp,
auf 2'500 m Höhe.
Die Vorbereitung für eine Fahrt über
die Anden oder ein grösseres Gebirge
ist natürlich extrem wichtig.
Das Wetter muss stimmen -
wie ist der Wind beim Start?
Habe ich überhaupt die Chance,
aus dem Tal zu starten?
Auch sicherheitsmässig usw.
Das muss man sich alles überlegen.
Damit man entweder starten kann
oder merkt, dass es nicht geht.
* Rasante Gitarrenklänge *
Aber je tiefer der Bus
ins Gebirge fährt,
desto schlechter wird das Wetter.
Stefan hatte zwar
eine Kaltfront erwartet -
aber diese Aussichten
bereiten ihm Sorgen.
Die Gruppe erreicht das Basecamp
in Puente del Inca.
Von hier aus wollen die Ballon-
piloten am nächsten Tag starten.
Aber Stefan hat Zweifel.
Es schlug mir im ersten Moment
schon auf die Laune.
Ich fragte mich:
"Muss das jetzt sein?"
Und ich merkte,
dass es daran scheitern könnte.
Jetzt sind wir schon
so weit gekommen, bis hierhin,
und wegen einer Kleinigkeit
geht es dann trotzdem nicht auf.
Das produziert in so einem Moment
schon ein wenig Stress.
Es ist Mitternacht.
Reiseführer Joseph verspricht den
Piloten, dass die Körbe und Ballone
pünktlich am nächsten Morgen
eintreffen werden.
Und dass sich das Wetter
bessern sollte.
Trotzdem machen sich
viele Teilnehmer Sorgen.
Als erfahrener Profi versucht Stefan,
die Gruppe zu beruhigen.
... Really strong turbulences,
already with 20 knots.
Da sind Piloten dabei,
die es sich nicht gewohnt sind,
voll in den Bergen zu fliegen -
wie wir in den Alpen.
Da merkte ich, dass es noch Infos
braucht für gewisse Leute,
nicht dass man im Nachhinein
sagen muss:
"Hätte er das gewusst,
wäre es nicht passiert."
Keiner denkt daran,
ins Bett zu gehen.
Noch bis tief in die Nacht
wird weiter diskutiert.
Ob die spektakuläre Ballonfahrt
über die Anden am nächsten Tag
tatsächlich stattfinden kann,
steht in den Sternen.
Wir befinden uns in Osttimor.
Der kleine Inselstaat
liegt in Südostasien
und gehört
zu den ärmsten Ländern der Welt.
Let's pray. We thank you
for giving us opportunities.
Blessing us, each and every day.
Heiliger Vater, ich danke dir für
die Menschen, die uns unterstützen.
Ich möchte auch dankbar sein
für unser Team hier.
Beschütze die Frauen und Männer,
die heute eingeliefert wurden,
und gib den Ärzten die Weisheit,
um sie richtig zu behandeln,
damit sie schnell gesund werden.
Morgengebet auf dem Flughafen
der Mission Aviation Fellowship,
kurz MAF.
Das christliche Flugunternehmen
hilft Menschen in Not -
mit Hilfsflügen
und mit dem Beistand von ganz oben.
Die Vision ist,
dass wir Leute, die abgelegen leben,
unterstützen und ihnen helfen.
Und dies mit der Liebe, die wir
zu Gott haben und Gott uns gibt.
Daniel Moser arbeitet seit
vier Jahren als Pilot für die MAF.
Heute muss er sich um Probleme
auf einer Landepiste kümmern.
Der heutige Plan ist,
dass wir nach Lospalos fliegen,
ein kleiner Ort ganz im Osten
der Insel, 45 Min. von hier.
Wir müssen
mit einem Bauarbeiter schauen,
ob sie die Löcher im Runway
flicken können.
Für die Sicherheit ist es extrem
wichtig, ein Fluglandefeld zu haben,
auf dem wir landen können,
ohne einzusinken.
In Lospalos
ist das gerade nicht der Fall.
Bei starkem Regenfall
wird der Boden, rund 150 m, weich.
Dann können wir dort nicht
aufsetzen, wir würden einsinken.
Daniel
hat eigentlich Schreiner gelernt.
Danach ging er
als Fallschirmaufklärer
mit der Swisscoy der Schweizer Armee
in den Kosovo.
Clear Prop. Prop ist clear.
* Ratternde Motorengeräusche *
It is Monday morning.
Nach seiner Zeit im Kosovo
heuerte Daniel bei der
Mission Aviation Fellowship an.
Die christliche Organisation
ist in 26 Ländern im Einsatz.
Dank ihr konnte sich Daniel
hier in Osttimor
zum Missionspiloten
ausbilden lassen.
Der Glaube an die christliche Lehre
treibt Daniel an, Gutes zu tun.
Letztendlich hat jeder Mensch
gewisse Fähigkeiten und Stärken.
Ich bin in einem Elternhaus
aufgewachsen, in dem ich viel bekam.
Ich bin überzeugt, dass der
christliche Glaube den Ursprung hat,
dass wir anderen helfen -
in welcher Form auch immer.
Für mich ist das eine Art,
wie ich diesen Leuten helfen kann,
in der Zeit, in der ich hier bin -
in der Schweiz sieht es anders aus.
Für mich ist momentan dieser Glaube,
den ich habe,
der christliche Glaube,
ist die treibende Kraft dahinter,
die mich hierhin gebracht hat.
* Emotionale Klänge *
Osttimor ist ein kleiner Inselstaat
zwischen Indonesien und Australien.
Die Halbinsel hat 1 Mio. Einwohner,
aber nur jeder zweite
hat Zugang zu sauberem Trinkwasser.
Ein Drittel der Bevölkerung
ist arbeitslos.
Um Hilfseinsätze fliegen zu können,
müssen die wichtigsten Landebahnen
in einem guten Zustand sein.
Diese Piste ist nach starken
Regenfällen voller Schlaglöcher.
Aber bevor Daniel
dieses Problem lösen kann,
muss er sich
um etwas Dringenderes kümmern:
Ganz in der Nähe hat eine Frau
einen Herzinfarkt erlitten.
Okay and we can take
one patient with us.
Okay, great. Yes.
Vielleicht ist es Fügung,
dass der Schweizer zur richtigen
Zeit am richtigen Ort ist:
Der Krankenwagen bringt die Patientin
innert Minuten zum Flugzeug.
Sie muss schnellstmöglich
ins Krankenhaus.
Was hat die Patientin
für ein Problem?- Herzinfarkt.
Daniels Transportflüge
können in Osttimor Leben retten.
Viele Gebiete auf der Insel sind
mit dem Auto nur schwer erreichbar,
und eine Fahrt ins nächste
Krankenhaus würde Stunden dauern.
Daniel und sein Team fliegen
v.a. kranke ältere Personen,
Kinder und Neugeborene Ð
ohne den Flugtransport
könnten diese nicht überleben.
Sie gehen generell anders um
mit Leben und Tod.
Der Tod ist viel näher als bei uns.
Wenn man hier
etwas Schlimmeres hat ...
Bis man im Spital ist,
vergeht so viel Zeit.
Ja, das ist die Realität hier.
Der Schweizer fliegt die Patientin
ins 200 km entfernte Spital
in der Hauptstadt Dili.
Die Maschine fliegt vorbei
an bis zu 3'000 m hohen Bergen
und überquert dichten Regenwald.
* Eindringliche Klänge *
Ich habe gar nicht geschaut, wie alt
sie ist und was mit ihr passiert.
Ich schaue das medizinische Trans-
ferformular jeweils nicht genau an.
Es ist sicher gut,
dass sie jetzt ins Spital kommt.
Ob sie sich vom Herzinfarkt
erholen kann, weiss ich nicht.
Ja ... Das hat sicher einen Einfluss
auf ihre Gesundheit.
Seit vier Jahren fliegt Daniel
Hilfseinsätze in Osttimor.
Mittlerweile hat er akzeptiert,
dass das Leben hier
nach anderen Regeln funktioniert.
Man wäre frustriert,
wenn man das Gefühl hätte,
dass diese Insel
schweizerisch funktionieren muss.
Das wäre nichts.
Aber hinter diesem Tor wartet dafür
ein kleines Stück Heimat auf ihn:
Seine Frau Deborah und Sohn Eli.
Hey, du, ciao.
Kommst du zu Dada?
Dada!
- Hallo.
Was hast du heute gemacht, Eli?
- Lauter Blödsinn.
Lauter Blödsinn? Nein.
Ja, ja, ja,
jetzt gibt es gleich ein Geschrei.
* Hupen *
Du könntest doch gleich Auto fahren,
Eli?
Komm, wir gehen essen, mjam, Pizza.
Es gibt Pizza!
Für mich ist das
das Highlight des Tages:
Wenn ich nach Hause komme,
meine Frau sehe und den Kleinen,
der auf mich zukommt.
Das ist sicher
ein Austausch von Liebe.
Beten wir, Eli.
Ja, beten.
- Dann essen wir weiter.
Vater, wir sind dankbar für den Tag,
den wir hatten,
für das, was wir erledigen konnten,
aber auch das, was mühsam war.
Wir danken dir, dass es Abend ist
und dass wir Essen haben. Amen.
Ich bin mega froh,
dass du Pizza geholt hast.
Eli hat Katzenfutter gegessen heute,
wieder einmal.
Aber du musst doch nicht
Katzenfutter essen, du.
Ich dachte, er nimmt das dann
irgendwann mal in den Mund.
Das ist etwas vom Wichtigsten
im Leben,
dass man diese Gefühle austauscht
und nicht für sich behält.
Denn ich bin überzeugt, das, was am
Schluss bleibt, ist nicht das Geld,
es sind nicht Dinge,
die ich heimbringe,
diese Beziehung ist das Wichtigste.
(Beide) # I ghöre es Glöggli,
das lütet so nätt.
# De Tag isch vergange,
jetzt gahn i is Bett.
Zurück in die Schweiz,
nach Amriswil im Kanton Thurgau.
Auf diesen Tag hat Jonas Langenegger
sehnsüchtig gewartet.
Heute kann er zum ersten Mal seinen
neuen Segelkunstflieger ausprobieren.
Aber zuerst muss er
fertig zusammengebaut werden.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
Also, ich schaue noch kurz,
was wichtig ist.
Ich habe eine Liste gemacht,
da staunst du, oder?
Er hat einen eigenen Flieger
und nimmt das ernst.
Der Flieger ist halt noch neu.
Ich will ihm sowieso Sorge tragen -
aber jetzt ist es schon anders.
Ja, damit ich sicher nicht schon
bei der Montage einen Fehler mache -
es wäre schade, wenn ich
nachher nicht fliegen könnte.
Okay, drehen.
Gut schauen.
Du kannst ihn anheben,
dann tragen wir ihn beide zusammen.
Irgendwie ist etwas nicht ganz ...
Hier muss man
durch drei Dinge durch.
Ich glaube, das ist drin.
Es ist ungewohnt,
weil es ein polnischer Flieger ist,
da ist alles ein wenig anders.
Später versuchen wir mal,
zu fliegen.
Das Wichtigste ist,
sich an den Flieger zu gewöhnen.
2018 wurde Jonas
Weltmeister im Segelkunstflug,
und zwar in der Kategorie Advanced.
Jochen Reuter ist sein Trainer.
Beim Aussenrollenkreis
ist der Anfang wichtig.
Du hebst ihn leicht aus, das kannst
du am Anfang bewusst machen.
Wie mit der 21.
Jetzt schiebt der so hin, du kippst
das Seitenruder nach oben.
So hast du die Nase oben -
jetzt geht es automatisch.
Jetzt stösst du einfach durch, zack.
Du hast die ersten 45.
- Genau.
Du drehst weiter,
das Seitenruder in Kurvenrichtung.
das Seitenruder immer noch oben.
Es ist oben, wenn du weiterdrehst.
- Genau, ja.
So und jetzt: genau so, zack.
Die Koordination ist ganz anders
als beim normalen Fliegen.
Die Eindrücke, die Beschleunigung,
die Geschwindigkeit, der Horizont.
Man hängt in den Gurten,
der Flieger schiebt.
Das ist so anders
als das normale Fliegen,
man muss das lange und ausführlich
üben.
Jetzt muss ich noch dehnen.
* Unverständlicher Funkspruch *
Ja, ich bin gleich bereit.
(Funk) Wie schnell möchtest du
geschleppt werden?
Ach so, wie schnell. 130 wäre gut.
* Elektronische Klänge *
Als Fluglehrer ist man sich gewohnt,
seine Kenntnisse weiterzugeben.
Es macht Freude, wenn das so junge
Leute sind, die es umsetzen.
Und es z.T. genau so machen, wie
man es gerne selbst gemacht hätte.
* Treibende Klänge *
Bei solchen Figuren
wirken enorme Kräfte von 7G.
Jonas wird mit dem Siebenfachen
seines Gewichts
in den Sitz gedrückt.
Jede Bewegung
wird vom Trainer genau beobachtet.
Dieser spricht das Feedback
auf ein Diktiergerät.
Auf die Drehgeschwindigkeit achten.
Die erste war ca. 25°.
Und der Rest auf 80°.
Er ist auf jeden Fall
ein ausgesprochenes Talent.
Das verführt ihn manchmal dazu,
zu glauben, alles gehe von selbst.
Das tut es nicht.
Aber das gehört auch zur Entwicklung
eines Sportlers dazu.
Dieses Programm will Jonas
an den Schweizermeisterschaften
in drei Monaten
vor einer Punkte-Jury fliegen.
Für den ersten Flug
war das nicht schlecht.
Es waren die typischen Probleme,
die immer auftreten.
Das ist eine Frage der Zeit,
bis es gut klappt.
Es macht Spass -
aber es gibt noch einiges zu lernen.
Die erste Figur
gelang mir erstaunlich gut.
Aber das war wohl
eher Anfängerglück.
Aber die ersten Rollenkreise waren
noch nicht so, wie sie sein sollten.
Der 25-Jährige
ist ein Ausnahmetalent.
Er will sein Können in diesem Jahr
in der höchsten Segelflugkategorie
beweisen - der Unlimited-Klasse.
Die bekannten Figuren waren gut, die
unbekannten müssen wir noch üben.
Das war zu erwarten.
Und den Stil - von Anfang an
exakter und akzentuierter.
Ja.
- Gut.
Im Prinzip das Gleiche noch einmal.
- Ja, ich glaube auch.
Mein Ziel ist, an den Schweizermeis-
terschaften aufs Podest zu fliegen.
Es gibt natürlich auch einen Druck,
weil ich in der Kategorie Advanced
die Weltmeisterschaft gewonnen habe.
Jetzt will ich auch in der Kategorie
Unlimited ganz vorne dabei sein.
Doch dort ist die Luft dünn, nur
die Besten treten gegeneinander an.
Bald wird sich zeigen,
ob Jonas mit ihnen mithalten kann.
In Argentinien,
genauer in Puente del Inca,
steht dem Schweizer Ballonpiloten
Stefan Zeberli
die wohl abenteuerlichste Fahrt
seines Lebens bevor.
Gemeinsam mit 50 anderen
Ballonpiloten aus aller Welt
will Stefan auf 7'000 m Höhe
die Anden überqueren.
Bis jetzt habe ich alle Sauer-
stoffflaschen von Josef gesehen.
Ich glaube,
ich gebe die alle runter.
Dann haben wir ein bisschen Platz.
Die Ausrüstung ist erst
vor ein paar Stunden angekommen.
Es ist cool,
dass die Ballons hier sind.
Die Lastwagen
haben sie in der Nacht hochgelassen.
Ich war mir nicht sicher,
ob das klappt.
Etwas weniger cool sind nach wie vor
die vielen Unklarheiten.
Es sieht nicht gut aus.
Ich suche noch
meine Sauerstoffflaschen.
Wir haben sie im März
nach Spanien mitgeschickt.
Wenn sie nicht da sind,
werden wir nicht fahren.
Der Korb ist da.
Ich muss dort drin suchen.
Wir können
den ganzen Müll rausschaffen.
Vielleicht ist es unter dem Müll.
Hier ist viel Zellophan.
Gestern hat das schlechte Wetter
für dicke Luft gesorgt.
Heute soll es besser werden.
Aber ohne Sauerstoffflaschen
nützt das alles nichts.
Wer hat die Ballons gepackt?
War das Josef oder eine Tochter?
Ich habe dir eine Flasche gegeben,
die vielleicht geht.
Die kleine?
- Ja. Zeig sie mir mal.
Nein. Auch nicht.
(In dem Moment war es eine
grosse Stresssituation für mich.)
Da habe ich schon überall geschaut.
Aber ...
(Ich nutze ein relativ komplexes
System der Sauerstoffspeisung.)
(Aber das kann ich
nur mit Flaschen betreiben.)
Für was für ein System ist das?
- Keine Ahnung.
Die kann ich nicht brauchen.
(Sie hatten zu lange Hälse.)
(Sie hatten zwar dasselbe Gewinde,
aber der Anschluss passte nicht.)
Ich fahre nicht, wenn wir nicht ...
Was für eine Scheisse.
Ich habe zwei Flaschen
runtergeschickt - beide nicht hier.
(Ich dachte, das könne nicht sein.)
(Ich habe alles nach Spanien
geschickt. Dort wurde es verpackt.)
(In Container.)
(Und in Argentinien
ist das Zeug nicht mehr da.)
(Das kann ich nicht einordnen.)
Wer hat das Material
in Spanien gepackt?
Warst du dabei?
Wir haben zwei Zweiliterflaschen
mitgeschickt.
Mit dem Ballon.
Wenn die nicht hier sind,
kann ich nicht fliegen.
Das ist ein hoher Berg.
Mittlerweile sucht Stefan seit 2 Std.
nach seinen Sauerstoffflaschen.
(Wir waren so weit.
Die Wetterlage passte perfekt.)
(Wenn es dann an einer Sauer-
stoffflasche scheitern würde ...)
Ja?
- Gefunden?- Gefunden.
Er hat wohl gerade die Flaschen
gefunden. Das wäre optimal.
Wem gehört die?
- Keine Ahnung.
Die war in einem Karton drin.
(Es waren amerikanische Systeme.)
(Die könnten passen.)
Es ist nicht diese. Aber die geht.
Der St. Galler
sieht eine Möglichkeit.
Die amerikanische Flasche könnte
auf seinen Schweizer Schlauch passen.
Nein. No.
It's too small.
It's a different type.
It's american style.
Nein. It's too small.
(Ich bin jemand,
der nicht einfach aufgibt.)
(Zu diesem Zeitpunkt war es für mich
nie ein Thema, aufzugeben.)
(Ich fragte mich:
"Was ist die nächste Möglichkeit?")
... to put down ...
It's an easy one.
- It's easier, yes.
So ... then Chris ...
Bist du einverstanden, wenn wir
hier schneiden und das machen?
Ich kann es abdichten. Okay?
Okay, then we'll do that.
Stefan will seinen Schlauch
so manipulieren,
dass er
auf ein spanisches Gewinde passt.
Es ist dasselbe Gewinde.
Vielleicht kann ich es befestigen.
Bring schnell den Regler.
Der Perfektionist,
der immer alles minutiös plant,
muss ausgerechnet jetzt
improvisieren.
Ich hole mein Isolierband.
Auch wenn dabei nicht alle verstehen,
was genau er da tut.
Gerade noch rechtzeitig
zum Sonnenaufgang
kann Stefan
seine Sauerstoffversorgung testen.
Ich habe eine Flasche.
Ja.
* Erleichtertes Ausatmen *
Nun ist auch er bereit
für den Startschuss
zur grossen Überfahrt.
* Rauschen *
* Ergreifende Musik *
Der Startplatz
liegt auf 2'500 m Höhe.
Aber die Ballonteams
wollen noch viel weiter hinauf -
bis auf 7'000 m werden sie steigen.
* Jubelrufe *
* Epische Musik *
Und die Sauerstoffflasche
funktioniert.
Hier über die Ohren.
Und jetzt hier unten festziehen.
* Rauschen des Brenners *
Wir sind auf 4'500 m, bald 4'600 m.
Wir steigen mit 2,5 bis 3,5 m.
Wir kommen jetzt ungefähr
auf Gipfelhöhe.
* Rauschen des Brenners *
Obwohl Stefan in 20 Jahren
rund 2'000 Fahrten gemacht hat,
geht für ihn heute
ein Traum in Erfüllung.
Es ist etwas vom Allerschönsten.
Ich durfte schon
viel Schönes erleben.
Aber das hier ist wirklich ... geil.
Es fühlt sich an
wie Weihnachten und Ostern zusammen.
Der Höhepunkt der Reise
steht Stefan aber noch bevor.
Morgen will er vom Ballon aus
die totale Sonnenfinsternis
über Argentinien beobachten.
Im Mittleren Westen der USA
ist Tornadosaison.
Seit einer Woche fahren
die Fribourger Dominic und Sascha
durch das grosse Land,
jagen Gewitterzellen
und wollen unbedingt einen Tornado
vor ihre Fotolinse bekommen.
Physiklehrer Dominic hat ein Gewitter
entdeckt, das es in sich hat.
Potztausend!
Es gibt zwar keinen Niederschlag,
das ist spannend.
Die Windstärke ist unglaublich.
Vor ihren Augen entwickelt sich
die perfekte Ausgangslage
für einen Tornado.
Und das nur
ein paar Kilometer entfernt.
Die beiden können es nicht glauben.
Oh, 10 %.
So etwas gab es
in den letzten Jahren noch nie.
Das ist unglaublich.
Das löst Staunen aus.
Jetzt nur keine Zeit verlieren:
Während Sascha
das Mietauto bereitmacht,
prüft Dominic,
was seine Konkurrenten -
die professionellen Stormchaser -
vorhaben.
Ich schaue noch kurz
die Chase-Versammlung an.
Nicht alle
haben die Signale eingeschaltet.
Aber diese hier
sind z.B. schon unterwegs.
Es gibt jene,
die die Signale erst einschalten,
wenn sie wissen,
dass sie am richtigen Ort sind.
Wenn sie falsch sind,
geben sie keine Signale.
Ich hoffe, dass nicht bereits zu
viele vor Ort sind oder sein werden.
Aber die Lage ist so klar,
wo man hinmuss.
Das Tornadojagen
ist in den USA Volkssport.
Meteorologen,
Hobbyfotografen, Journalisten
und ganze Busladungen von Touristen:
Alle wollen den Nervenkitzel
eines möglichst mächtigen Tornados
hautnah miterleben.
Schau dir diese Autos an!
Und Storm-Hunters sind auch hier.
Schau, Storm-Hunters.
Soll ich ihm
unsere Visitenkarte geben?
Die beiden Schweizer
halten sich von der Masse fern.
Sie wollen
ihren eigenen Tornado finden.
Vielleicht hat es auch
mit Stolz zu tun,
einen eigenen Tornado zu haben.
Wir möchten mehr oder weniger
nicht mit dem Mainstream mitgehen.
Wenn es das ist, dann ist es gut.
Dann ist es gut.
Auch bei den anderen Sturmjägern
herrscht nun plötzlich
Aufbruchsstimmung.
Während des Tages muss man Hunderte
Entscheidungen treffen.
Bis man diese gefällt hat,
ist man voller Zweifel.
Es können vier Superzellen
unterwegs sein,
und eine davon wirft den Tornado.
Welchen wähle ich nun?
Die grünen Punkte sind Stormchaser.
Unser Ziel ist:
weg von den Stormchasern.
Denn wir wollen
eine schöne Zelle haben
und sie am liebsten
für uns allein haben.
Während die anderen Tornadojäger
auf ein Gewitter im Norden setzen,
fahren die zwei Schweizer
ostwärts.
Roscoe -
das ist eine Ausfahrt vor Olchala
oder wie das heisst.
Ohlala.
- Ohlala, das klingt gut.
# Ohlala, jetzt geht's los.
Jetzt geht es nur noch darum,
rechtzeitig am richtigen Ort zu sein.
Hier ist eine schlimme Zelle
unterwegs.
Das könnte die stärkste Zelle sein.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie es ablaufen wird.
Verdammte Kackstrasse!
Tornadomeldung bestätigt. Zwei.
Jetzt ist es gelaufen.
Verdammt!
Jetzt ist der spannendste Moment
des Chasings:
Schaffen wir es oder nicht?
* Dramatische Musik *
Das Violett ist eine Tornadowarnung.
Es gibt einen sog. cell spit,
d.h., sie hat sich aufgeteilt.
Jetzt gibt es zwei Kerne.
Dominic muss sich entscheiden,
welche Gewitterzelle
er weiterverfolgen will.
Wir müssen uns in Position bringen.
- Ja.
Also, raus.
Und dann nach rechts.
- Rechts. Hier?
Geradeaus, ja.
Es ist immer noch
eine Tornadowarnung.
Geradeaus. Pardon, links.
Wir gehen geradeaus. Jetzt rechts.
Die erste Strasse.
Zweite Strasse, dann wieder rechts.
Nächste Strasse links.
Sorry, wir sind falsch gefahren,
weil es nicht nachgeladen hat.
Geradeaus.
Links, pardon. Sorry. Links.
Mein Wunsch wäre es,
ein wenig schneller zu fahren.
Aber nur wenn es geht.
Aber nach den vielen kleinen Irrwegen
scheint sich der Sturm plötzlich
in Luft aufgelöst zu haben.
Siehst du noch etwas vom Lefty?
Keine Ahnung. So schnell sah ich
noch nie eine Zelle zusammenfallen.
Obwohl die Wetterdaten
einiges mehr versprochen hatten,
bleibt zum Schluss einmal mehr
nur ein Regenschauer übrig.
Vielleicht
wäre die andere Gewitterzelle
doch die bessere Wahl gewesen.
Unsere Zelle sah lange besser aus.
Jetzt sieht die andere besser
aus und hat eine Tornadowarnung.
Die Zelle ist zusammengefallen.
Das ist ein frustrierender Moment.
In der Regel bin ich dann
sehr betrübt und still.
Ja ...
Die Enttäuschung ist da.
Man studiert Modelle, fragt sich,
ob man am richtigen Ort ist.
Dann entscheidet man sich -
und plötzlich
sieht man alles zusammenfallen.
Nein ...
Ach.
* Mehrstimmiges Vogelzwitschern *
Frühmorgens im Busch
von Botswana
ist Christian Gross
mit seinem Landrover unterwegs.
* Erhabene Musik *
Das ist ein junges Weibchen.
Links von ihm
steht ein noch jüngeres Weibchen.
Das sind Nachzügler
einer kleinen Herde,
die schon auf die andere Seite
gegangen ist.
Das ist ein Wunder der Natur
und eine wahnsinnige Schönheit.
Aber der Alltag im Paradies
ist auch unberechenbar.
Christians Frau Misha ist Notärztin
bei der Okavango Air Rescue
Ihr Tag beginnt ganz anders.
One, two, three.
* Schmerzensschrei *
- Stop. That's good, well done.
Wir sind in der PC-12.
Und wir fliegen nach Gabarone
mit einer schwer kranken Frau.
Die Ursache
ist eine Schwangerschaft,
die nicht mehr intakt ist -
d.h., das Kind ist tot.
Das Kind wird dann entfernt werden.
Sie ist schwer krank.
Sie hat ein Nierenversagen.
Sie braucht intensive
medizinische Betreuung hinterher.
Ich bin Optimist.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass wir sie
während des Fluges stabilisieren.
In Gabarone
können sie das weiterführen.
So kann sie geheilt werden.
Die Farm von Misha Kruck
und Christian Gross
liegt mitten in Botswana.
Die beiden Weltenbummler haben
hier im afrikanischen Okavango-Delta
vor sechs Jahren
die Okavango Air Rescue gegründet -
eine Rettungsflugwacht
ähnlich der Schweizer Rega.
Als wir 2011
zum ersten Mal hier waren,
hatte es kurz vorher
einen sehr dramatischen
Flugzeugabsturz im Delta gegeben.
Alle Menschen, die in der Maschine
waren, kamen ums Leben.
Es hätten Leute überleben können,
wenn Hilfe dagewesen wäre.
Uns wurde die Aufgabe
praktisch in die Arme gelegt:
"Warum macht ihr nicht
eine Rettungsflugwacht auf?"
Irgendwann haben wir gesagt:
"Ja, warum eigentlich nicht?"
Sie macht Gott sei dank
das Ärztliche.
Und du machst Gott sei dank
das Geschäftliche.
Das ergänzt sich zu 100 %.
Die Okavango Air Rescue
hat mittlerweile 20 Mitarbeitende.
Mit einer PC-12 fliegt sie
24 Std. am Tag Rettungseinsätze.
Christian
will seinen Betrieb ausbauen
und bald ein zweites Flugzeug kaufen.
Darum braucht sein Team neue Piloten.
Die werden vom italienischen
Chefpiloten Aldo instruiert.
Wir müssen
drei weitere Piloten anstellen.
Darum zeige ich ihm heute
das Flugzeug - die PC-12.
Er hat noch nie eine gesehen.
Dann muss er sein Training machen,
um die Fluglizenz
für diese Maschine zu bekommen.
(Zuerst zeige ich ihm ein paar
typische Eigenschaften der PC-12.)
(Und die nächsten Tage wird er
mit mir als Co-Pilot fliegen.)
(So kann ich ihm
die ganzen Abläufe zeigen.)
Dann muss er mir zeigen,
ob er die Maschine beherrscht.
* Spannende Klänge *
(Ich denke, die grösste
Schwierigkeit im Busch von Botswana
ist das Wetter.)
(V.a. der Wind
und die Temperaturen.)
(Im Sommer kann es im Dschungel
bis zu 38 oder 40 °C heiss werden.)
(Durch die Hitze
ist die Dichte der Luft viel höher
und das Flugzeug hat weniger Schub.)
(Ein Start mit einer schweren Fracht
kann darum
ziemlich schwierig werden.)
* Spannende Klänge *
(Und dann gibt es natürlich Tiere.)
(V.a. beim Start und bei der Landung
sind die
eine grosse Herausforderung.)
(Den Zebras oder Elefanten
sind wir egal.)
(Die bewegen sich einfach nicht.)
(Darum fliege ich vor einer Landung
zuerst zwei- oder dreimal
ganz tief über die Piste.)
(Möglichst schnell und möglichst
tief, um sie zu erschrecken.)
(Aber die denken nur:
"Geh weg, das ist mein Platz.")
(Schon als ich zum ersten Mal
mit einer PC-12 geflogen bin,
dachte ich: "Das ist
eine fantastische Maschine.")
(Du kannst sie sehr hoch fliegen
und auch sehr tief.)
(Sie ist schnell
und hat einen starken Motor.)
(Natürlich ist sie kein Jet.)
(Aber für eine Propellermaschine
ist sie top.)
Auch Jonas
hat einen wichtigen Tag vor sich:
Heute hat er sein Flugzeug verpackt
und will damit verreisen.
Für den letztjährigen Weltmeister
geht es heute mit zwei Freunden
ins Trainingscamp nach Deutschland.
* Dynamische Musik *
(Für die Schweizer Meisterschaften
ist dieses Training
besonders wichtig für mich.)
(Ich kann mir
Zeit fürs Training nehmen.)
(Bei vielen Sachen denke ich noch:
"Es ist noch nicht so,
wie es sein sollte.)
(Ich muss das Vertrauen haben,
zu fliegen.)
(Und ... äh ... ich möchte auch
die Bestätigung von anderen,
dass es von unten
vernünftig aussieht.)
Jonas will hier die Figuren
der höchsten Flugkategorie Unlimited
erlernen.
Hilfe erhofft er sich vom Trainer
der deutschen
Segelkunstflug-Nationalmannschaft.
George Dörder
ist eine Koryphäe im Segelkunstflug.
Hallo, George.
- So, jetzt, Jonas.
Ich grüsse dich.
- Wieder so viele Gesichter hier.
Wie geht es euch?
Seid ihr gut hergekommen?- Gut, ja.
Ich freue mich, dass er den Übergang
in die Unlimited macht.
Das wird nicht ganz einfach sein.
Aber er hat gute Anlagen
und ein gutes Flugzeug.
Wenn er gut angeleitet wird,
wird er sich in der Schweiz
relativ schnell nach vorne arbeiten,
auch in der Unlimited.
Für den Aufstieg
in die nächsthöhere Kategorie
muss Jonas ein Programm
mit vorgegebenen Figuren fliegen.
Wir zeichnen hier
ein klassisches Programm.
Hier sind die einzelnen Figuren.
Das ist z.B. eine gerissene Rolle
auf den Rücken.
Auf dem Rücken,
dann wieder gestossen zurück.
Das ist in dieser Klasse
das Spezielle - das habe ich
noch nie vorher trainiert.
Es ist für mich
die grösste Herausforderung,
diese zu trainieren.
Das Schweizer Team
war in letzter Zeit sehr erfolgreich.
Niemand zweifelt daran, dass Jonas
mit der Konkurrenz mithalten kann.
Er ist ein Mensch
mit extrem viel Talent.
Letztes Jahr konnte er an der WM
sehr gut punkten.
Jetzt ist er in einer neuen Klasse.
Mal schauen, wie das geht.
Er muss neue Figuren und neue
Abläufe lernen. Aber das packt er.
* Dynamische Musik *
Jonas
wird in seinem neuen Segelflugzeug
auf knapp 1'600 m gezogen.
Dort klinkt er sich aus.
Und jetzt
trägt ihn nur noch der Wind.
* Dynamische Musik *
Aber was für die meisten
imposant aussieht,
hat für Trainerlegende George Dörder
noch viel Luft nach oben.
Gnadenlos spricht er seine
Manöverkritik auf ein Diktiergerät.
Die Schnauze höher nehmen.
Richtung Süden.
Insgesamt meiner Meinung nach
sogar ein bisschen zu flach.
Nach 25 Min.
ist Jonas zurück auf dem Boden
und hört sich die Kritik an.
Jetzt stehst du
ganz deutlich übersenkrecht.
Das hat man
schon von Rom aus gesehen.
Zu früh eingefangen.
Mit dem Querruder
sehr viel nachgesteuert,
das Seitenruder
aber noch stehen lassen.
Dadurch hattest du
einen grossen Schiebewinkel.
(Als ich das gehört hatte,
dachte ich mir: "Scheisse.")
("Fliege ich so schlecht?")
Schätzungsweise noch ...
... 300 oder 400 Trainingsflüge in
den nächsten zwei bis drei Jahren,
damit hier eine Präzision reinkommt.
Wie gesagt: Er fliegt
einen einigermassen guten Standard.
Aber er fliegt noch
keine Achter- oder Neunerfiguren.
Er fliegt auch ...
Na gut, es ist Figurentraining.
Er fliegt auch noch viele Dinge
etwas zu unruhig.
Er muss noch
Ruhe und Eleganz reinbringen.
Diese harsche Kritik
ist Jonas nicht gewohnt.
In drei Monaten findet
die Schweizermeisterschaft statt.
Er wagt den grossen Sprung
in die höchste Kategorie, Unlimited.
Bis ein Anruf
sein grosses Ziel zunichte macht.
Der Organisator teilt ihm mit,
dass die Kategorie Unlimited
in diesem Jahr
nicht durchgeführt werden kann.
Ich bin der einzige Teilnehmer
bei Unlimited.
Wenn ich allein
bei Unlimited fliege,
kann ich nicht
Schweizermeister werden.
Ja.
Ein harter Schlag für Jonas.
Scheinbar vergeblich hat er sich
drei Monate lang vorbereitet.
Ich habe dieses Jahr
extra für Unlimited trainiert.
Ich möchte gerne zeigen,
was ich geübt habe.
Und schauen, ob es gut ist. Ja.
Aus der Traum vom Schweizermeister.
Weil Jonas nicht genügend Gegner hat,
kann er keinen Titel gewinnen.
Drei Monate Training umsonst.
Die Absage ist auch abends
am Lagerfeuer das Hauptthema.
Für mich ist das Ziel
auch Wettbewerbe zu gewinnen.
Ich würde nicht teilnehmen,
wenn ich wüsste, ich werde Letzter.
Das wäre für mich enttäuschend.
Dann wäre ich auch für den nächsten
Wettbewerb nicht motiviert.
Jonas hat keine Lust,
an der Meisterschaft teilzunehmen.
Ohne Konkurrenz
gibt es für ihn nichts zu gewinnen.
Eine Teilnahme wäre nicht mehr
als ein Training fürs nächste Jahr.
Wenn du keine Konkurrenz hast
für Unlimited,
musst du deinen Fokus anders setzen:
dass du nächstes Jahr
an die Unlimited-WM gehst.
Mit dem Nachteil, dass du jetzt
Unlimited allein fliegen musst.
Jonas lässt sich überzeugen.
Schliesslich will er
an die Weltmeisterschaft.
Ich habe mir andere Ziele gesetzt:
keinen Nuller zu fliegen.
Dass jede Figur klappt
oder zumindest wertbar ist.
Das ist für Unlimited
ein gutes Ziel.
Titel hin oder her -
Jonas will sein Bestes zeigen.
* Entspannte Elektroklänge *
Sonntagmorgen in Osttimor,
Südostasien.
Daniel Moser und seine Familie
widmen diese Zeit Gott -
in der Hauskirche,
gemeinsam mit Freunden.
Vater, ich bin dir dankbar,
dass ich dich Vater nennen darf.
Dankbar,
dass du mir ein guter Vater bist
und ich mit dir
in einer Beziehung sein darf.
Es ist wunderbar, dass du
mich akzeptierst, so wie ich bin.
Ich muss dir nichts beweisen,
sondern kann immer zu dir kommen.
Danke, dass du heute
für uns da bist. Amen.
* Babyquengeln *
Die Kirche ist für mich
etwas völlig Normales.
Dazu pflege ich eine Beziehung.
Wir sprechen über das,
was wir praktizieren.
Wir haben einen Glauben,
der uns vereint.
Der christliche Gedanke dahinter
ist, dass wir anderen helfen wollen.
Um anderen helfen zu können, müssen
wir mit uns im Reinen sein
und uns klar sein, was wir
auf den Tisch bringen können.
Ein Teil davon ist, unsere Schwächen
zu erkennen und daran zu arbeiten.
# You say I am loved
when I can't feel a thing.
Daniel ist überzeugter Christ.
Vor acht Jahren
hatte er ein Erlebnis,
das sein Leben
für immer verändert hat.
Damals war er Fallschirmaufklärer
für die Schweizer Armee.
Es war eine spezielle Begegnung.
Wir waren mit der KFOR
im Kosovo im Einsatz.
Bei einem Ferienflug
sass ich im Flieger.
Die Tür beim Cockpit war nicht zu,
je nach Links- oder Rechtskurve
schwenkte sie auf und zu.
Wir flogen durch die Wolken.
In diesem Moment
hörte ich eine Stimme.
Das erlebte ich
vorher und nachher nie mehr.
Ich hörte: "Möchtest du fliegen?
Möchtest du für mich fliegen?"
Ich wusste, das war Gott.
Ich hatte nichts dagegen und sagte:
"Ja, ich versuche es."
Achte Jahre später
sind wir hier gelandet.
So wird Daniel Pilot
bei der Mission Aviation Fellowship,
einer christlichen Hilfsorganisation.
Seit vier Jahren
lebt er ein Leben als Missionar.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
das Wort wird oft falsch verstanden.
Für mich ist das mein Glaube
und mein Leben.
Und es gibt
viele verschiedene Arten,
wie ein Christ
seinen Glauben auslebt.
Ob jemand eine Kirche aufbaut
oder ob jemand
ganz praktisch fliegt.
Was auch immer:
Es spielt keine Rolle.
* Funkspruch auf Englisch *
Der Inselstaat Osttimor liegt in
Südostasien nördlich von Australien.
Er ist nur ein Drittel so gross
wie die Schweiz
und hat gut 1 Mio. Einwohner
I should be there in about
20-25 minutes. So it's all good.
* Sanfte Musik *
Täglich ist Daniel mit der Realität
im drittärmsten Land der Welt
konfrontiert.
Seine Arbeit ist hier bitter nötig.
Heute muss er zwei Patienten
transportieren.
Ein elfjähriger Junge mit Verdacht
auf Denguefieber
und ein Neugeborenes mit Atemnot
müssen ins Spital.
* Ein Baby schreit. *
Doktor!
* Er spricht Portugiesisch. *
Dem Baby geht's nicht gut,
wir müssen vorwärts machen.
Die Strassen sind schlecht, es
kommt nur ein Flugtransport infrage.
Aber die Propellermaschine kann
höchstens fünf Personen mitnehmen.
Es wollen viele mitkommen.
Ich kann aber nur die zwei Patienten
und je ein Familienmitglied
mitnehmen.
Und den Arzt.
(Ich bin
ein stark sachorientierter Mensch.)
(Mir fällt es oft schwer,
mich in andere Leute einzufühlen.)
(Das ist sicher von Vorteil,
wenn ich in der Situation bin.)
(Dann blende ich das aus.)
(Aber manchmal holt es mich ein,
wenn ich in ein Gesicht schaue.)
(Bei Kindern ist es oft ...)
Als Eli noch klein war ...
Ich hielt den Kleinen auf dem Arm
und wusste,
dass jemand
gerade mit den Tränen kämpft
und das Leben
gerade nicht so schön findet.
Der Schweizer hat gelernt,
mit den oft belastenden Situationen
seines Berufsalltags umzugehen.
Als Rettungspilot
muss Daniel pragmatisch entscheiden.
Emotionen
haben im Cockpit nichts zu suchen.
(Es kann schon sein,
dass es mir sehr nahe geht.)
(Z.B. wenn ich sehe,
dass Kinder sterben.)
(Oder Teenager.
Das ist wirklich schwierig.)
(Es gibt kein Cockpit,
das von der Kabine abgekapselt ist.)
(Ich kriege alles mit.)
Ich glaube, es besteht die Gefahr,
einfach wegzuschauen
und auszublenden.
Aber das kann ich hier nicht.
Ich bin täglich damit konfrontiert.
Mir bleibt nur etwas übrig:
dankbar zu sein.
Es ist nicht selbstverständlich,
dass die Familie gesund ist,
dass es uns gut geht
und wir Unterstützung haben.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Es ist schon schwierig, ja.
Das kann man
nicht einfach ausblenden.
Ob die beiden Kinder
überleben werden,
wird Daniel
erst in ein paar Tagen erfahren.
Ballonfahrer aus aller Welt suchen
auf 7'000 m ü.M. das Abenteuer.
In einer einzigartigen Expedition
überquerten sie
die argentinischen Anden.
Heute soll
die Krönung des Spektakels folgen.
Momentan
ist praktisch nichts heikel.
Es ist fast windstill am Boden.
Wir haben schönes Wetter.
Eigentlich perfekte Bedingungen
zum Ballonfahren.
* Jubel, Gesprächsfetzen *
Der Hauptgrund, wieso wir
nach Argentinien reisten,
ist die totale Sonnenfinsternis.
Eine totale Sonnenfinsternis
aus dem Heissluftballon zu sehen -
diese Chance gibt's wahrscheinlich
nur einmal im Leben.
Wow.
Heute ist es so weit.
Zusammen mit 50 anderen Piloten
möchte sich Stefan
diesen unglaublichen Moment
auf keinen Fall entgehen lassen.
Das gibt sagenhafte Bilder.
Die totale Sonnenfinsternis
dauert etwas mehr als 2 Min.
Dann muss man zur richtigen Zeit
am richtigen Ort sein.
Das Timing ist so: Um 17.30
müssen wir in der Luft sein.
Wir beginnen um 17 Uhr, die Ballone
aufzublasen und aufzuheizen,
sodass jeder um 17.30 Uhr
startklar ist.
Ich habe schon als Kind
eine Sonnenfinsternis gesehen.
Ansonsten hatten wir
in der Schweiz extrem Pech -
auch bei der totalen 1999,
das Wetter war immer schlecht.
Ich habe noch nie eine totale
Sonnenfinsternis gesehen
und freue mich extrem darauf.
Ursprünglich
kam der Wind eher von Südosten,
darum richteten wir zuerst auch in
diese Richtung ein, das war perfekt.
Die meisten begannen,
die Ballone aufzublasen.
19 oder 20 Ballone.
Um 17.10 Uhr
hat der Wind plötzlich gedreht.
Das passierte schlagartig.
Wir müssen drehen.
Die Luft rauslassen!
Oben halten, oben halten!
Darum waren wir komplett falsch. Der
Wind kam von oben gegen den Ballon.
Gegen den Wind kann man
den Ballon nicht aufstellen.
Wir mussten zuerst alles umdrehen.
Wann ist die Sonnenfinsternis?
Jetzt gibt es doch noch Stress.
Wir müssen oben halten,
hier rauf lassen.
Wenn die Luft draussen ist, drehen.
Nein, das glaube ich nicht.
Die 20 Teams müssen ihre Ballone so
schnell wie möglich neu platzieren.
Sonst wird es zu dunkel, um überhaupt
noch rechtzeitig starten zu können.
Alles rauslassen. Fest ziehen!
Loslassen, loslassen!
Hier lassen wir raus.
Stefan gehört zu den erfahrensten
Piloten auf dem Platz.
Er rennt von Ballon zu Ballon,
um den anderen zu helfen.
Sobald wir einen Pick-up haben,
holen wir einen.
Willst du aufstellen,
bei diesem Wind?- Ja, ja.
* Rufe *
Es war ein totales Chaos.
I can't hold the car!
Es war zu viel Wind, um vernünftig,
im offenen Feld starten zu können.
Urs, pass bitte auf!
No, no, no, Joseph!
No, it's too early!
Why he took off like this?
It was clear that it was too early.
Das hätte nicht sein müssen, es war
doch klar, dass es viel zu früh war.
So ein Scheiss.
Ein paar Ballonpiloten haben es
geschafft: Sie sind in der Luft.
Stefan und sein Team
gehören nicht dazu.
Das Hauptproblem ist,
dass es zu viel Zeug hat hier.
Wenn man alleine wäre, könnte man
los in die Windrichtung.
Der Wind flacht eher ab.
Wären wir doch
30 Min. früher gestartet.
Aber jetzt
ist es wieder viel besser.
Ja, das dachte ich auch,
darum warteten wir.
Wir holen uns sofort einen Pick-up.
Die Franzosen brauchen sofort
einen Pick-up, Urs.
Dann ging der Wind
für einen Moment deutlich zurück.
Da konnte man es versuchen.
Wenn es so bleibt, starten wir.
Ein letzter Versuch:
Das Gewicht des Autos soll den Ballon
so lange wie nötig am Boden behalten.
Aber direkt neben Stefan
startet bereits ein anderer -
und der versperrt ihm den Weg.
Stefan versucht zu helfen,
um endlich selber starten zu können.
Away, away, away!
Come here!
Hey, jetzt müsst ihr aufhören.
Haltet die Leine hier,
haltet die Leine!
Ich weiss jetzt nicht,
was hier passiert ist.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik,
Stimmengewirr *
* Hupen, Jubel *
Auch dieser Ballon
schafft es noch in die Luft.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob wir das machen wollen.
Die Sonnenfinsternis
ist sowieso bald komplett.
Nur Stefan
bleibt auf dem Boden zurück.
We stay on the ground,
because it's too late.
Wir beobachten jetzt, ob der Wind
zurückgeht, das ist möglich.
Wenn nicht,
werden wir wohl nicht fahren.
I think it's too late.
Im US-Bundesstaat Colorado
ist das Wetter genauso schlecht
wie die Laune der beiden Tornadojäger
Dominic und Sascha.
Ihre vielversprechende Gewitterzelle
hat sich vor ihren Augen
in Luft aufgelöst.
Ich brauche jeweils einen kurzen
Moment, um mich zurückzubesinnen,
denn die Enttäuschung ist da.
Man schaut Modelle an, man fragt
sich, ob man am richtigen Ort ist.
Und auf einmal sieht man,
wie alles zusammenfällt.
Ein Jahr lang haben die zwei Freunde
für diese dreiwöchige Reise gespart.
Das Ziel war es, ein paar tolle Fotos
eines Tornados nach Hause zu bringen.
Doch bis heute haben die beiden
nur Regen und Wolken gesehen.
Wie sieht es südlich aus?
- Noch nichts.
Ich wollte noch das Satellitenbild
anschauen.
Vielleicht hier.
Hier kommt keines, oder?
- Nein.
Vielleicht ganz knapp,
aber es fällt alles zusammen.
Nicht einmal der starke Niederschlag
nützt uns.
Ganz wenig West ...
- Ich würde leicht West machen.
Eine Weile vergehen lassen
und dann den Aufwind anschauen.
Das ist das Schönste, was wir
machen können - oder siehst du ...
Nein. Jetzt warten wir diese Zelle
ab und schauen, was passiert.
Dominic und Sascha fahren
einmal mehr in Richtung Denver.
Im Norden von Colorado
sei die Tornadowahrscheinlichkeit
momentan sehr gross -
sagen ihre Berechnungen.
Tatsächlich
braut sich ein Sturm zusammen.
Die beiden entdecken
direkt vor ihnen eine Gewitterzelle.
Haben die beiden tatsächlich
einen möglichen Tornado vor sich?
Dort wäre der Entstehungspunkt
eines Tornados.
Aber ... Wir schauen mal.
Man sieht eine sog. Wallcloud,
dort hat es Aufwind.
Auf der rechten Seite
sieht man ein Schwänzchen,
da geht es hoch, und in der Mitte
sieht man ein Wölkchen.
Das kommt weiter nach unten
als das rundherum.
Rotiert das?
- Ja, das ist ein Tornado.
Und zwar ein grosser.
Kannst du aufmachen, bitte?
Ja, ah, scheisse.
- Danke.
Von einem Tornado spricht man erst,
wenn die Luftspirale auch tatsächlich
den Boden berührt.
Ah, Tornado!
Es geht immer hoch und runter -
vielleicht gibt es mal Bodenkontakt.
Man sieht die Rotation der Wall-
cloud, man sieht, wie sie rotiert.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Das war wohl schon alles.
Mal schauen,
aber es sieht nicht gut aus.
Dort kommt aber auch etwas runter.
Nur ein Foto
würde Dominic schon reichen.
Wir haben das GPS-Signal verloren,
wir sind wahrscheinlich zu nahe.
Das GPS-Signal fiel raus.
Wir müssen weiter.
Es ist wirklich haarscharf,
ca. 500 m zurück.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Sicher die Hälfte vergessen -
so wie immer.
Auch Jonas
hat einen wichtigen Tag vor sich:
Heute beginnt die Schweizermeis-
terschaft im Segelkunstflug.
Tschüss.
- Gut, tschüss, viel Glück.
Dir gutes Ausschlafen.
- Pass auf dich auf.
Für die Teilnahme
in der höchsten Kategorie Unlimited
hat der Schweizer Hoffnungsträger
das letzte halbe Jahr hart trainiert.
Vor einer Woche
hat Jonas dann erfahren,
dass er der einzige Pilot
in dieser Kategorie ist.
Ein eigentlicher Wettkampf
findet deshalb nicht statt
und Jonas
darf nur ausser Konkurrenz starten.
Ich begrüsse euch herzlich
zu diesem engen Piloten-Briefing.
Speziell möchte ich die
Punktrichter/-innen begrüssen.
Der Chefpunktrichter
ist George Dörder.
Er hat das letzte Wort.
Beim Briefing dann
die grosse Überraschung:
Jonas wird heute doch nicht
ausser Konkurrenz fliegen.
Ich erfuhr gerade, dass ich
doch einen Konkurrenten habe.
Er hat schon Erfahrung
mit Weltmeisterschaften.
Darum wird es doch noch spannend
bei uns.
Er hat mit dem österreichischen
Piloten Siegfried Meier
einen Konkurrenten mit Weltmeister-
schaftsrfahrung bekommen.
Das wird vermutlich ein ganz
interessantes Rennen geben.
Sigi Meier,
ein österreichischer Pilot,
hat sich im letzten Moment
noch angemeldet.
Jetzt ist fertig lustig.
- Wir haben uns schon gesehen.
Er startet vor Jonas
und fliegt sein erstes Programm.
* Unverständlicher Funkspruch *
Die Jury am Boden entscheidet,
ob die Figuren präzise und elegant
geflogen werden.
Wer mehr Punkte erzielt,
hat gewonnen.
So, jetzt.
- Er ist nicht senkrecht.
Ja, gut.
Jonas und sein Trainer Torsten
beobachten den Österreicher genau -
und mit einer kleinen Portion
Schadenfreude.
Schulterwurf.
Hätte das ein Weibchen sein müssen?
- Nein, ein Männchen, oder?
Wenn der andere etwas patzt,
freut man sich schon ein wenig.
Das muss ich zugeben - ein wenig.
Zwei Nuller, oder?
Der Konkurrent hat sich
ein paar Patzer erlaubt.
Eine gute Ausgangslage für Jonas,
der zum ersten Mal
in dieser höchsten Kategorie startet.
Zwar kann er heute
keinen Titel gewinnen,
zwei Teilnehmer sind zu wenig.
Aber er kann seine Punkte
mit dem Konkurrenten vergleichen
und seine Leistung einordnen.
Ich bin gespannt, was er fliegt.
* Treibende, elektronische Klänge *
Oh, scheisse!
Das war nix. Er war zu langsam,
wartete zu lange.
Jawohl.
Ah, ein bisschen nachgesteuert.
Jawohl! Ah, der war nix.
Der war sehr teuer.
Vielleicht sind noch zwei Punkte
übrig geblieben - oder einer.
Ja, Mist, schade.
Aber sonst war's nicht schlecht.
Auch heute ist Jonas nicht ganz
zufrieden mit seiner Leistung.
Aber die Entscheidung liegt jetzt
ganz bei den Punkterichtern.
Wir kommen zur höchsten
Kategorie, es gab zwei Teilnehmer.
In dieser Kategorie
gibt es keine Wertung.
Es gibt eigentlich
keinen ersten und zweiten Platz,
sondern den ersten Sieger
und den zweiten Sieger.
Der zweite Sieger
in der Kategorie Unlimited ist ...
Sigi Meier.
Und der erste Sieger ist Jonas,
herzlichen Glückwünsch.
Jonas hat mehr Punkte bekommen als
sein österreichischer Konkurrent -
selbst er
ist ein bisschen überrascht.
Der strenge Juror George erklärt,
warum der Schweizer
trotzdem gewonnen hat.
Gut gemacht.
- Aber knapp.
Sigi ist die Rolle falsch geflogen.
Er hat 70 Strafrunden geholt,
das war dein Sieg.
So einfach ist es.
- Ja, aber nicht so ehrenvoll.
Das wird immer wieder so sein.
Wir sehen dich
bei der Weltmeisterschaft, oder?
Ja, ich habe es vor.
- Ja, klar.
Die Leistung ist auf jeden Fall
ausbaufähig.
Wenn er dranbleibt, sehe ich ihn
international bald in den Top 10.
Es freut mich natürlich besonders,
dass ich nicht noch zehn Jahre
Unlimited fliegen muss,
bis ich an die WM gehen kann.
Ja, ich denke ... Das ist schön.
Jonas kann sich jetzt in Ruhe
auf die Weltmeisterschaft
im nächsten Jahr vorbereiten.
Und vielleicht war dieser Tag
der Anfang einer grossen Karriere.
In Osttimor ist Missionspilot Daniel
auf dem Weg ins Spital.
Er will dort die Patienten besuchen,
die er in den letzten Tagen
im Flugzeug transportiert hat.
Meine Gefühle sind etwas gespalten.
Wenn es ein Happy End gibt, ist man
selbst jeweils auch glücklicher.
Aber die Realität ist, dass der
Bestattungsraum relativ gross ist.
Es kann also auch so sein.
Die medizinische Versorgung
hier in Osttimor
steht in keinem Vergleich
zur Schweiz.
Die Sterblichkeitsrate
lag letztes Jahr bei 46 %.
Es ist krass, wenn fast die Hälfte
in einer Holzkiste endet.
Das zeigt einmal mehr,
dass es uns hier noch braucht.
Daniel besucht das Spital nur selten.
Die Schicksale gehen ihm oft zu nah.
Ah, that's the kid.
Er trifft den elfjährigen Jungen
aus Same,
den er mit akutem Denguefieber
ins Spital geflogen hat.
Es geht ihm schon viel besser.
He looks much better.
- Yeah, he's getting better.
Das will man natürlich immer sehen.
Das ist schön.
Im Raum nebenan liegt das Baby,
das kaum mehr atmen konnte.
Daniel erkennt die Eltern wieder.
Very good to see.
Es gab schon Momente, in denen
das Baby keinen Mucks mehr machte
und ich Angst hatte,
dass etwas nicht gut war.
Darum ist es umso schöner zu sehen,
wie es atmet
und dass es ihm gut geht.
Ich hoffe, es kann bald wieder
nach Hause zu seiner Familie.
Man muss
auf die Sonnenseite schauen.
Das Leben als Rettungspilot
ist kein einfaches.
Aber Daniel
hat sich bewusst dafür entschieden
und seine Frau Deborah
unterstützt ihn auf diesem Weg.
Die schönen Seiten
dieses armen Landes
trösten die beiden immer wieder
über ihr Heimweh
und die vielen Entbehrungen hinweg.
Irgendwann werden wir ganz zurück
in die Schweiz gehen, das ist klar.
Nicht klar ist, wann. Heute und
morgen wohl noch nicht gerade.
Es ist noch nicht Zeit,
hier zusammenzupacken.
Wir haben beide das Gefühl, wir
haben hier noch etwas zu erledigen,
und es gefällt uns grundsätzlich
in Osttimor.
Ja, es ist noch nicht Zeit,
zusammenzupacken.
Der Weg hierher war zu lange,
als dass wir jetzt nach vier Jahren
schon wieder zusammenpacken.
Irgendwann wird das ein Thema sein,
aber im Moment noch nicht.
Und so wird Familie Moser
diesen Weg noch eine Weile gehen.
Damit Daniel den Einheimischen
aus der Luft helfen kann -
mit der Unterstützung von ganz oben.
Hast du Sand in den Augen?
Wohl eher Salz.
- (Lachend) Salz?
Der Mond schiebt sich
immer mehr über die Sonne.
Bald herrscht über den argentinischen
Anden eine totale Sonnenfinsternis.
Die letzten Heissluftballons
sind gestartet.
Aber Stefan und sein Team
sind noch am Boden -
und dort werden sie auch bleiben.
Ich bin enttäuscht,
dass es nicht geklappt hat,
weil wir ganz nahe dran waren.
Nachdem sie endlich
genug Platz hatten,
war es bereits zu dunkel,
um sicher zu starten.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
* Jubel, Applaus *
Wow!
Incredible. Look, the balloon!
Es war ein emotionaler Moment, mir
lief es kalt den Rücken hinunter.
Und dann noch die Ballons oben -
wenn sie heizten,
leuchteten sie wie Lampions.
Und doch schmerzt es ein wenig,
weil man weiss,
dass fünf oder sechs Ballons starten
und das beobachten konnten.
Die Sicherheit
steht bei so etwas an erster Stelle.
Das muss man immer auch realistisch
und vernünftig anschauen.
Diese Chance hat Stefan verpasst.
Dafür kehren er und sein Team
gesund nach Hause zurück.
In den USA
bahnt sich etwas Grosses an:
Erneut deutet vieles darauf hin, dass
der grosse Augenblick ganz nah ist.
Jetzt kommt er dann.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Wow, geil!
So schön!
- Wir haben's geschafft.
Das reicht wahrscheinlich schon.
* Dramatische Musik *
Tornado! Dort unten!
Er ist dort unten, Tornado!
Und tatsächlich.
Direkt vor ihren Augen
setzt der Wirbel auf dem Boden auf
und ist zum richtigen Tornado
geworden.
Die beiden Stormchaser
haben ihr Ziel erreicht:
ihren eigenen, kleinen Wirbelsturm.
Nein, ich will ihn noch filmen!
Auf meinen Fotos sieht man,
dass er unten am Boden ankommt.
Hier sieht man es nicht gut, aber
wir wissen es wegen der Struktur.
So ein schöner Tornado -
wir wussten erst nicht,
ob er dort drüben aufsetzte.
Hier hatte er Bodenkontakt.
Es ist einfach wunderschön,
das ist absolut genial.
Für diese Fotos sind die beiden
um die halbe Welt gereist
und tagelang durch die USA gefahren.
Da wird sogar Sascha etwas emotional.
Realisierst du es?
Das ist gut.
Über 10'000 km im Auto,
unzählige Stunden vor dem Computer
und unendlich viel Geduld
haben sich gelohnt:
Super.
Dominic möchte diesen Erfolgsmoment
als Erstes mit der Familie
zu Hause teilen.
Hallo, Jonas. Wie geht es dir?
- Gut.
Ich konnte einen wunderschönen
Tornado einfangen!
Er war sehr schön.
* Unverständlich *
Ja, er hörte fast nicht mehr auf
zu drehen.
Die Natur hat sich Dominic und Sascha
von ihrer beeindruckendsten Seite
gezeigt.
Genau der richtige Zeitpunkt,
um die Jagd zu beenden.
Die Luft, das Element zum Schweben,
Atmen und Träumen.
Sie bringt immer wieder frischen Wind
in unser Leben.
Und hilft uns, die Antworten
zwischen Himmel und Erde zu finden.
Dank ihr schweben wir auf Wolke 7.
Und sie lässt uns dem stärksten Sturm
standhalten.
Und egal, wie dünn sie manchmal wird,
sorgt sie dafür,
dass wir niemals aufgeben.
* Sanfte, hoffnungsvolle Klänge *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Michaela Hoss - 2022